generically named computer assistant
what is the current temperature right
now it's 96 degrees fahrenheit
hey it's rob and i'm a sucker for
punishment so i am
out here in the backyard i have
uh received my hopefully last shipment
of plants other than one which is coming
as a replacement for one that died in
the last shipment
i want to try and repot these and get
them stuck out front
i've got
seven seven jalapenos
and then four more reapers
some uh trinidad scorpions
and some ghost peppers uh i do have some
ghost peppers already i mean these are
these are not exotics by any means
they're
uh they're hot peppers but uh i wanna
try and
put them in pots and i got some new pots
that i want to try are these i think
these are the
two gallon uh
yeah it's hard to tell and it says 105
st so you know i'd say it's a it's a 105
st
i have no idea what that means but these
might just be the one gallon
i am not entirely sure but i think they
are big enough for
maintaining the root system of a pretty
healthily growing pepper plant
and i'm gonna try uh you know this is my
first time really doing a large pepper
grow in pots so
we'll see how it works out
this is my soil mixing system i have a
concrete mixture that i put the
dirt and whatever else in and
i mix it around for a while make sure
that it's pretty thoroughly mixed up
and then i can dump it in the weed
barrel the wheelbarrow
and put it into the pots i know that
sounds exciting doesn't it
[Applause]
that's enough for a pretty decent start
on these pots
i don't want to take all the soil out of
this because i might have more
that i'm going to be doing but i just uh
when i'm done with it i'll end up
putting it back in here until i can get
a large
you know five gallon pail to be able to
store it in one it's got a nice
convenient lid
that isn't cracked i made that mistake
what i want to do with these is fill
them up to within about four inches of
the top maybe a little bit
deeper than that
good couple shovelfuls
give it a nice bottom
a little bit more
i'm going to pack this down just a
little bit not a lot
uh to give it a base for the plants to
sit on so i'm going to
do this with the first eight
already some little plants growing in
here
this is the easiest way i've found of
doing transplants into pots
first of all we take the plant that we
are transplanting
uh these are i got from bonnie plants
which are pretty good
you want to break up the soil a little
bit
tease the roots out get them so that
they're
you know kind of running around in the
in the
soil a little bit looser and then just
pile in dirt around the outside
it's so much easier than trying to dig a
hole
in what was you know in soil that you
put in a pot
i like to fill these not quite up to the
top
and make a sort of a moat a little
depressive moat around
the roots like that keeping the stem
and the edges up it helps to you know
slice the water in a little bit
although it's not that important and of
course
keep the steaks in so that i know what
the what the peppers are
because until they start sprouting
peppers it's really difficult to tell
sometimes they don't want to come out
very well oh look at the roots on this
one
that's lovely
and by doing this you're going to do
some damage to the roots but
they will grow back very well
i like to keep these pots uh that the
plants came in because
they're still in pretty good shape and i
can use these for
sprouting seeds for next year
i am going to need to get more soil
because i still have 15 more of these to
go 16 if you include the one that's
coming
all right this is what i've got so far
for plants and pots
get these growing in here
now there is one thing that i don't
really like about well a couple things i
don't particularly like i do have some
growing in
in these which have had surprisingly
good results over the past
few years it's kind of amazing that they
don't need
nearly as much soil as you think they do
although these go down into the dirt i
mean they they grow roots
down into the soil so they get plenty uh
but these guys i have to weed
and that's okay it's not a lot but you
know
it's enough of a pain in the butt
because i do have
a lot of a lot of pots growing here
and then of course there is the uh the
in-ground garden
now i'm using this uh this house wrap
as oh look at the ants i am using this
house wrap as
a weed block and it's
more weatherproof than the normal weed
block that you see over there
but it really cuts down on the weeding
uh there's some stuff that will grow
under there creeping charlie in
particular but
uh you know i've got quite a few plants
in here
and they are doing quite okay now one of
the nice things is i set up this
water irrigation system with the soaker
hoses
and that has done remarkably well in
keeping these guys watered
right now i've got it i think dialed
into about
30 minutes once a day and
there are four zones and they all run at
different times so it's not over
saturating
all the soil at one time it's kind of
spreading the love
i am going to have to do some more
weeding in the
you know on the periphery and some of
that but
uh this is i'm not sure what i'm going
to do with this yet
uh ideally this would go into the
territory of
a whole house air conditioner but
that's probably not going to happen
anytime soon so i might
end up moving creating a mulch pile back
here a compost pile
because right now these are my compost
bins
uh it's all leaves
and organic material i mean the tea bags
are
tea bags are all biodegradable so they
will eventually
degrade down the little metal staples in
there are steel
and they will degrade into iron which is
actually fairly good for plants
it's not in huge huge levels so it's not
going to be
toxic at all
these guys these tall boys are something
else
i got these from frostbed peppers and he
grew them
he started them really early
i think around uh super bowl weekend i
think is when he said he started him
so they got a pretty good head start and
uh
they seem to be doing okay i was a
little worried that they might have some
issues because they're so tall
but they seem to be standing up for
themselves pretty well
yeah i know there's traffic noise
there's not much i can do about it
because there are cars on the road
i've got 15 more 16 technically
to put in pots i'm not going to do it
today because i am out of soil
to put in the pots i'm going to have to
go to the hardware store tomorrow
they're closed already
it's a little later in the evening so
you know a little cooler which is nice
but i'm going to try and do those
tomorrow weather permitting and see
if i can get all of them planted
one of the nice things about growing in
pots is that as the plants grow bigger i
can move them
and i can give them more space and i can
rotate them around in different areas so
that they can get more or less sun
as needed uh i don't know this is my
first year doing anything quite this big
so we're gonna give it a shot and see
how it goes
anyway uh i'm gonna do the other ones
tomorrow i'm not going to do them
tonight
because it's still pretty freaking hot
and i'm tired
i'll see you guys next time peace